welcome to this video playing hmm Kira
meet you all I cannot pronounce that
Kira me me TC on d6 g6 kind of setup
yeah you allow me this gain of time I'll
do it yeah very often black will just
lose yeah exactly all this time back end
Bishop Bishop goes back to g7 those kind
of things and here we have a fairly
standard power he took that now that's
not that standard anymore now this is
just good for white yeah it is good
because of them the better structure
just wonder how to play it Bishop f4 or
Bishop g5 it's not much but white white
should have something ok maybe we should
be 5 i'm not not totally sure Queen a5
might be possible
my ideas the move 94-94 Queen III
pinning on the night okay so queena 3
where are you going to d7 yeah it's
going down well I have not be five and
and ideas like that 19 5 maybe maybe
Quincy six
mm I p5 Quincy 6i can take 97 okay so
let's do that
not quite sure where he's going I mean
probably 285 the move Knight e5 is some
is however a problem and one that I only
saw quite late yeah well just create
five I guess it's not doing that not
sure why okay maybe there's no need of
course that's possible Bishop e3 again
night maybe 95
yeah that's not that great actually this
whole thing 95 move with some more than
annoying Queenie three
should give form
I originally wanted to play a 3 Queen B
2 and then attack the queen with rugby
one but you just go back off the way to
have six if everything else fails he can
do that and he has probably better moves
okay so okay I'm going to grab him it's
not what I wanted but a six I go a three
no one no one never knows what's going
on down chan that was bad really with
night b5 and so on the idea with Knight
e5 for black I really underestimated
easiest is to just take it now in the
Queen that were easiest I have to do it
it's just it's just the only move
sometimes if you argue and or think and
there's really no need 97 I would like
to play so let's go back and prepare
that so 967 right look 28 maybe okay i'm
starting with that
one issue is CF in any kids night c7
look to 896 Fe six then the the the F
file is getting opened up this is not
really to my advantage Bishop F to these
kind of things but it's it's nothing I
mean I cannot really do anything about
it I'm what's the best way to do it we
should be four maybe we should be 42 f
three maybe okay yeah this is this is
this should be it should be fine now
now that that's fine I don't have to
very much am I deal leave I get in
Bishop g5 I know that one
yeah I mean this is no problem already
time warning check
I can I know this is a counter check
better not okay so let's see H flow I
guess check I'm threatening g5 with the
mating net this is the idea what check
checkmate okay yeah sometimes just
threaten made might materialize I hope
that I stood okay with the with the
activity I mean but maybe not maybe not
yeah a comp says I'm losing okay yeah I
couldn't really very much about it I had
to had to make moves check it seems that
a three was was winning I thought that
this might be a counter play I age five
saves them okay this is what he has to
do I mean save some and wins I have no
maid and then the airport is too strong
yeah then where do you add where did I
screw that out then or I can just take a
seven it's very stupid not to take that
one I was actually thinking that this is
just totally dead anyway canta let's
just stop the case really not a force
bet I am this takes this makes him spend
more time and this is also better yeah
probably it is it is some kind of draw
still but yeah I'm interested about the
opening because this really should be
something for wide but it really didn't
it really didn't look like it might be
five year rooks you born yeah this this
is just not good yeah the main point is
that this is not a good move
I didn't really think about it I didn't
really understand that 95 is always the
key move that gives him a decent
position and here I'm just not
coordinated well Oh a six was impossible
I was thinking a three but the computer
points out correctly that him this is
quite a double attack hmm yeah full of
mistakes this game I hope you enjoyed it
anyway thanks for watching